- [Instructor] When we
think of British colonies
in the Americas before 1776
we tend to think of the 13 colonies.
Those colonies that were located
along the eastern seaboard
of North America and which rebelled
as a group in the American Revolution.
But if you were standing in London,
say 1770,
and you were thinking about British
colonies in the New World,
it's more likely that your thoughts
would have turned to the Caribbean,
what they called the West
Indies and the sugar islands
of Jamaica or Barbados,
than say the colony of New Jersey.
Because even though this was quite
a gigantic swath of territory,
these tiny little islands in the Caribbean
were incredibly profitable
for English investors.
Because sugar was a commodity that fetched
very high prices in the Colonial Era.
In this video I want to focus
on the southern colonies
and the British colonies in the Caribbean,
which although they were
somewhat separated in land.
Got them next to each other here,
but kinda imagine that
this is the tip of Florida.
So that belongs down here,
and all these little
islands in the Caribbean
are far to the south of
mainland North America.
So what united these colonies,
even though they were
divided in geography,
is that they were plantation colonies.
They were in southern or tropical regions,
which meant that they
had long growing seasons
that made them ideal
for planting cash crops.
That is crops that are
specifically grown to be sold.
Now we've already talked
a little bit about
the crops of Virginia,
which would be tobacco,
but in this video I want to talk
a little bit more about two other crops.
Sugar, which was grown in the Caribbean,
and rice, which was
grown in the Carolinas.
Growing these cash crops for export
was the main focus of these colonies,
and their social structures were organized
around producing those cash crops.
So let's talk bout sugar.
Now we hardly think about consuming sugar
in our tea or coffee today,
but in the Colonial Era it
was an incredible luxury
and it commanded very high prices.
One of the reasons for this is because
sugar was extremely
labor intensive to make.
The sugarcane plant is
actually indigenous to Asia,
but Europeans brought it to the New World
with the hopes of turning
it into a cash crop.
They planted it in the
tropical areas of the Caribbean
and then they imported enslaved Africans
to work on their sugar plantations.
Now you can see a little
bit in these two prints
of what sugar processing was like.
You would have to grow the cane stalks,
press the juice from them,
boil the juice until it created crystals.
Sugar processing happened 24/7,
and unlike tobacco you
really had to be very wealthy
to grow sugar because it required
a huge capital investment upfront.
You had to buy a lot of land
and grow a lot of sugarcane
and get a lot of machinery if you hoped
to produce enough to make a profit.
So a handful of very
wealthy plantation owners,
who mostly stayed in England
because the tropical diseases
of the Caribbean were too
likely to kill them off.
These sugar barons had
unimaginable wealth.
The tobacco planters of Virginia
were nothing compared to them.
And they were ruthless
about turning a profit.
In fact they thought that
it would be more profitable
in the event of the
deaths of enslaved people
from overwork or disease or some kind
of accident in sugar processing,
to just replace enslaved workers
rather than make their
work less dangerous.
Growing sugar was so profitable
that the Caribbean islands,
which were so small, couldn't
even spare room to grow food.
They imported all their
food from elsewhere
so that every square inch of
arable land in the Caribbean
could be used to grow sugar.
Now with so many enslaved people
coming into the Caribbean,
by the mid 1600s, enslaved
Africans in the Caribbean
far outnumbered white people.
And consequently the white slave owners
became increasingly
fearful of slave uprisings.
So plantation owners who were,
of course, in control of
the colonial government
began to crack down on enslaved people,
codifying the racial status
of enslaved Africans.
In 1661, Barbados passed a slave code
that was incredibly harsh.
I won't go into all of it
here but the gist of it
was that the lives of
enslaved Africans were
to be very closely monitored.
They would require passes to travel.
They had no legal rights.
And if a slave owner maimed
or killed an enslaved person
there would be no repercussions
for that violence or death.
We will see aspects of
the Barbados Slave Act
in the statutes passed in the
southern mainland colonies,
and later southern states
in the United states.
And although we tend to
think of plantation slavery
generally looking like
the slavery we would see
later in Georgia or South Carolina,
large cotton plantations,
for the vast majority
of enslaved Africans,
their experience would have been much more
like what we saw in the Caribbean.
In fact, 90 percent of all enslaved people
were sent to the Caribbean
or South America.
Only a little over 300,000 would be sent
to mainland North America.
So if you're looking for
the most typical experience
of slavery from the point of view
of the people who lived it,
life on the sugar plantation
was a much more likely
prospect than life on a cotton plantation.
In fact it was English
planters in the Caribbean
who decided that they might strike north
to create a new plantation colony,
which they called Carolina
after the English King Charles.
Now Carolina was founded
as one big colony in 1670,
but by 1712 it was
separated into two colonies,
North Carolina and South Carolina.
And the wealthy plantation
owners who founded Charles Town,
also named after King Charles,
brought most of the aspects
of plantation slavery
they had picked up in
the Caribbean with them.
The Pass System, the lack of legal rights,
the lack of repercussions for whites.
One main difference, however,
was that in the Carolinas rice cultivation
took the place of sugar cultivation
as the main cash crop.
Plantation owners quickly
discovered that many West Africans
had worked on their own rice
farms before enslavement.
And so they particularly wished
to purchase West Africans
to work on rice plantations.
This is an image here
of a rice plantation.
Obviously, this a photograph,
so it would be from a
couple hundred years after
the settlement of the Carolinas,
but I think it gives you a sense of what
rice cultivation looked like.
I want to finish by just
briefly talking about
the colonies of Maryland and Georgia,
which were also plantation colonies.
But I've grouped them together because
they were both founded
for altruistic reasons.
They were proprietary colonies originally
like Pennsylvania, for example,
meaning that they were the
possessions of one person
rather than a company or the crown.
Maryland was founded in
1632 by an English catholic
named Lord Baltimore who wanted
to create a haven of religious freedom
for Catholics in North America.
In 1649, Maryland passed
the law concerning religion,
also known as the Maryland
Act of Toleration,
which extended religious
toleration to everyone
who believed in Jesus.
So all Protestants, all Catholics,
but on the flip side
it prescribed death for
anyone who did not believe in
Jesus like Jews or Atheists.
Georgia was founded a
century later in 1732
by an English humanitarian
named James Oglethorpe.
And Oglethorpe was
trying to reform prisons.
In England people who
couldn't pay their debts
were thrown into debtors' prison,
which was kind of silly because
when they were in prison
they didn't have the
opportunity to try to make money
to pay back their debts.
So Oglethorpe founded
the colony of Georgia
with the idea that people
who were suffering from debt
could go to this new
colony and work it off.
And for that reason he
also outlawed slavery
in the early years of Georgia's existence,
but by about 1750 the
pressure to include slaves
in the Georgia economy
so that it could keep up
with South Carolina, for
example, grew too great.
And so slavery was permitted.
So although the colonies
of the West Indies
and the southern part of North America
were in different places
and sometimes founded
for different reasons,
they were all united by the fact
that they relied on slavery,
and in many cases had a much larger
enslaved African population
than white population.
And they focused for their economies
on plantation agriculture.
Now you'll notice that in this video
I haven't spent much time talking about
the experiences of
enslaved African people,
and that's because I want to devote
another video to that.
So check out our video
on Atlantic slavery.